est-ce qui est pas un truc est pire que
mourir finalement c'est d'y penser
non c'est se réveiller vivant en trophée
recueil oui je suis pense des poètes un
nom peu de tout ça c'est parce que j'ai
beaucoup de
beaucoup de friperie mais là non comme
la zoophilie tout ça le sujet où ça
c'est bête et on n'y pense pas trop y
penser plus souvent bien non est-ce que
tu as donc s'il va pas peur de
travailler vivant dans un cercueil
non vraiment la regarde pourtant il ya
un truc contre aujourd'hui encore comme
en témoignent certains rescapés il
subsiste un risque non négligeable
d'être enterré vivant dans de
l'ouverture de ses recueils n'est pas
rare que l'on retrouve certaines preuves
plutôt macabre corps ayant bougé
griffures sur le couvercle ou phalange
déchiqueté voire carrément dévorer mais
j'entendais parler
saissac extraordinaire où il pensait que
tu es mort et mémoire dont nous entendez
parler alors qu'il était prêt à me
mettre à la morgue
en fait je me suis réveillé c'était
vraiment prendre in extremis une
personne peut être enterrés vivants
parce qu'il ya une erreur de diagnostic
sur sa mort dire qu'on sait très bien qu
entre la vie et la mort il ya toute une
série demeure provisoire que l'amour
n'est pas définitive et à la limite on
peut donc on peut se dire que des
personnes qui sont enterrées vivantes
sont en même temps tout à fait
consciente et à dire qu'elles peuvent
être dans la terre et leurs principes
conscient peut être au dessus en train
d'observer l'enterrement mais
rassurez-vous grâce à l'invention de cet
ancien ressuscité sauvé de justesse aux
portes du cimetière alors qu'il était
déjà dans son cercueil vous n'aurez plus
besoin de hurler ou de vous débattre
dans votre ton pour que l'on vous libère
verre et de métal est royalement jeu
peut actionner la sirène même des
pompiers jusqu'à 10 km je lui enverrai
avec la tête à droite comme ça donc je
n'ai la sirène sur celle de gauche
en ce moment la tête ça vaut alors si je
mets la thèse tir gauche la sirène va
sonner sans route en même temps poule
valtteri
du tout
automatiquement si je mets mon bras au
loyer siffle mais comme ça c'est facile
s'il écarte les bras mais voilà si
j'écarte les pieds et voilà je mets le
pied droit
[Musique]
l'association internationale pour
l'étude des états proches de la mort
réclame aujourd'hui la généralisation de
ce type de cercueils
il permettrait de sauver toutes les
victimes de ces coma trompeur que les
médecins connaissent encore mal
seul inconvénient à une telle mesure les
cimetières risques de plus en plus de
ressembler à la place de la concorde à
six heures du soir
et tu dit ont actuellement des cercueils
à sonnette gérard jugnot à l'oreille
doucement intox intox
pourquoi moi je trouve ça pas dans le
sud
tu vas pas cru quand ils vous souhaitez
s'affairant toi moi je trouve s'est
présenté d'une manière humoristique
c'était déjà arrivé et ça m'étonnerait
pas un gars traumatisés
oui ça y arriver je crois si oui si
c'est vraiment ça lui arrive et je pense
qu'on va en sortir tellement de troubles
et ça m'étonne pas qu'ils s'organisent à
dangy un fou tu dis info toi tu dis
comme gérard jugnot se donne à fond on
peut à la fois un bon bah on sait pas on
écoute l'expert philippe guérand bravo
gg bravo efforts c'était de l'info bravo
à tous
va pas repartir les mains vides c'est
mon oncle ouais chaleur pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu